for Franklin how are you good
you mentioned here take this you
mentioned about the difference between
about things becoming more analytical
this is more subjective what I find an
interesting phenomenon is that the
evaluation of the analytics is highly
subjective and somebody can look at
something and draw conclusions without
as you said context or experience or
knowing how things behave in knowing a
bigger picture and then try to run with
that information or you find yourself
having to explain to people that there
are different ways to look at those
analytics so so that's right that gets
back to the people you know we're flawed
right you know that's the bleep that's
why this will never end there are humans
are humans like we're gonna continue to
go through this sounding role right like
if this was all math the shoot over a
long time ago
right and that's like creativity matters
and that's why leadership matters and
charisma at all yes you're damn right by
the way
it's how we stumbled into our best case
study we right now have a lot of
momentum in the market especially since
less of days times because it was
feature than that we took over brand at
Mondelez Nilla wafer crackers we luckily
by accident I'd love to take credit by
accident it just worked out that we
ended up with all the function right it
was an entrepreneurial grant meaning you
had no real money and so we took it but
then lucky at the last minute there's
this three hundred thousand other
dollars I was gonna spend up you know
like a promotion that didn't happen so
we ended up with all of it right some
brand for thirteen years that's been
flat all we did was produce content on
Facebook Twitter and Pinterest that's
what we do for a living and net-net the
brand is of nine percent this year they
sold stuff it works I know this because
I applied it to my wine business and to
my books I know this stuff works it's
easy when I'm in control of the boss of
these things I don't have to have a
report to convince somebody it's not
subjective to me I'm not trying to get a
promotion and so you know that's a big
deal right you want to know what the ROI
is back you know the host who's talking
about like finding ROI like that was
real ROI you really show a lot of stuff
we got lucky so now I'm actually like I
didn't want big brands I want little
brands that only spend with us so we can
keep proving it cuz it's enough you know
it's the government they used to piss
the [ __ ] out of me with a TV right
because when I first got into this
everybody puts the other I'm social
media like I'm like well I'm not sure I
think I know this is a real Commerce
these are real conversations like I
think I know but before before I can
answer that
back to how you self this question I
would ask people and say can you just
how do you guys quantify the ROI of PR
and radio and television
and banner ads like how do you guys do
that here and the [ __ ] that I got and so
nobody amateur nobody and all characters
some people you are starting to realize
when I started backing people into the
corner because I was like listen I want
to win here I don't want you have a
client for one year or any five-year
clients to like maybe like this is my
work and I'd really push them into the
corner but wait a minute this is this
seems like black magic like TV didn't
work there you did a shopper marketing
campaign and put your product as an end
cap for those same three weeks that'll
[ __ ] soap your [ __ ] and when it
finally finally finally would net out
when I'm get somebody frustrated because
I'm gonna let them off the hook because
very honestly I was rich when I started
the company that sounds ridiculous I'm
trying to beat you picture why I was
willing to push harder right like I was
fortunate I already built a business so
I didn't really need to lay on this
client do it right I
I pushed up into water and this is the
answer that everybody remembers a lot of
agency people you're lucky but this is
the answer I would always get that Garin
you know it's fair but here's what I
know when I run TV it's social you know
that's really funny Carl I go nine
million dollars and four hundred
thousand on digital I'm like listen dick
get me nine million let me do all
digital and let's see what happens the
problem is as we all know is Carl scared
he'll get fired if you actually did that
if the sales don't come through and I
respect that at first I'm given then
I've learned and I've learned one of the
main strips of all this stuff and the
bottom line that Nets out is the
leadership of these companies need to
empower people to be able to have the
right mix TV's not dead inches v
understand how to market on TV like how
many people here is a good little
question how many people here in 2013
outside of live sports and live shows
DVR'd on-demand HD on the go
you watch your favorite shows when you
want to please raise your hand don't lie
thank you everyone just curious how many
people here fast forward in every single
commercial it's not the impression it's
about the attention great you're a trend
I wasn't paying attention I was tweeting
right and so meanwhile our clients
or spending millions of dollars trying
to tell stories and places where people
are running away from theirs listen
there's reasons why big companies go out
of business
this is change right now is one of them
there's a reason
while we're out of business they didn't
understand retail operations that the
Walmarts and the Costco's figured out it
was a innovation changed we are in a
massive storytelling innovation change
this isn't news you know room
this isn't silly stuff this is a big big
big deal the eyes and ears of our
consumers are shifting fast at record
speeds and the attention is moving even
quicker and the people that figure out
how to tell stories and their value
problem within the world that we
actually live in will win we have a
bunch of smart people in this room who
live in 2014 but market in 2008 I'm
trying to figure out listen because I'm
kind of not scared I'm trying to get the
dialogue out there like we just are
making the right decisions you know that
starts with agencies actually being
aligned with clients there's a retiring
one of the pieces like that works but it
was the execute the idea listen I need a
lot of people that come from all these
great weather ship the great people just
weren't hiring quickly surrender viewing
and people are smart when I think we're
getting caught as execution I think a
lot of you ironically everybody likes to
pick on strategy I think a lot of people
strategies are actually good but by the
time it goes through this [ __ ]
process its vanilla right and we're not
executing with teeth because I'll be
scared it's all questions so so should
brands even why should a brand have a
voice it's a faceless corporation well
they have a personality they want to
sell [ __ ] right and so I think it's
smart to have a voice because the cost
of having one is so low thing comparison
to what they've done forever which is
they rented an opportunity to have their
voice heard for a quick moment in time
and then every year they had to pay
again to rent an opportunity to tell
their voice which oh my weight change
dat lunch of times multiple times the
other thing is let's talk about the
lease for a second
we have to get out of this voice
conversation I think about these
meetings where we sit in a room and me
he's like humanize our brand and say oh
here's our ran her name's Laura she's 29
she has two and a half kids she is the
third person in her friend group to know
about the coolest new restaurant over
his [ __ ] exercise and he's no [ __ ]
sense other than other than it actually
does make sense but the executions where
I get pissed
meaning 29 year-old Laura when she goes
to work as an executive and an important
company has a certain voice right now
every person this room is acting very
differently in this week today than they
will when they go with their girls to
Vegas for the row and we are not
respecting the rooms were telling
stories in you can have your voice right
fine I'm down you're sorry you're sassy
you're great [ __ ] awesome the problem
is our brands and our businesses and the
businesses in this room want that same
voice applied everywhere but the reality
is that if one of you knows that you act
differently with your loved ones than
you do with your acquaintances the way
you do tonight at a cocktail party
versus the way you do if you go to a
presentation thing we act differently in
places so we're not respecting context
at all or just not respecting it and so
I love the voice exercise but I've got
to do something different and Tumblr
than I do in Facebook because the
audience is different and if you want to
win you need to roll different we're in
a slang marketing now right that's all
read you can know the slang the room
your story tell otherwise you're out you
can act really out of touch real quick
and we've seen it Hey what's your name
I shower
no it's better to be full of [ __ ] yeah I
mean right but you know it's harder when
that beta reading does prettier Changmin
doesn't hear or baby a dustman and
somebody leaves and like yeah I mean
this is you know it's easier for a human
being than a brand to be completely
consistent because we don't tend to
create ourselves out to somebody else
right but you know but I think often
thing is not that hard
meaning it's back to the cliches that we
all get you know wrap ourselves around I
mean when I think about authentic I'd
like to change the thought of that
definition at least and what we all do
what we're talking about - are we
bringing value to the person right like
you know authentic to me are we
authentic to armpit again it's so
subjective you know to me when I'm more
focused on is I think it's a lot easier
to respect the platform nuances then the
subjective nature of the creative and I
think people need to triple down on that
and let the subjective human thing just
be subjective human thing it works
itself out nobody's not too crazy you
know it's not like you know nobody's own
soul I mean these things that people get
think about like one adjective that like
is the same goddamn word but like the
manager decided look up silly instead of
funny face
so when you're trying to produce content
for brands I don't fear is a big part of
that conversation
I mean not overtly people don't come to
you and say we're really afraid but
that's what ultimate ultimately comes
across and you know especially big brand
gets a lot to protect what can you do
you minimize that fear you know besides
offer them assurances that you won't
take their brand you're right I think
one of the things that I give a lot of
thought to is I tell them the story VP
that really dumped so much little the
ocean it's not unheard of they basically
ruined the earth right nobody here
stopped going in populous six of my
friends in BP like an Instagram photo
like that
if a picture I mean like you know I
think that people are crippled by dumb
[ __ ] right like yes we may put it out
like you put out something and it didn't
go I mean like 18 T is not out of
business because the ridiculously
tasteless piece of content around 9/11
right and so I think we think I think we
all take ourselves way too seriously
on the upside and on the outside and so
we just you know we listen it helps when
you are run by a company that is run by
a guy like me that walks in and says
that directly to their face right so
like I think that's a true answer I
would hope in every organization there's
someone there with backbone and
understanding that if you don't have the
real conversation you never have the
real conversation and so we just have a
real conversation which is like listen
we know we're doing we put up forty
thousand pieces of content this year
already like we feel pretty damn good
about what we do we've been all in on
this back to the earlier point I've been
doing it since then get ready been
putting up Facebook and Twitter content
since those six of seven have understood
it you know but things are gonna happen
humans are flawed there's gonna be a
mistake
but I think people are taking it too
seriously people are on the defense
instead of being on the offense you've
way more to lose by making all this
neutral and vanilla than you do by I
heard earlier the last game about legal
we're in a lot of places where we know
of course we have legally
we've got a place we're testing without
legal approval you serve building trust
right
it takes time but this will happen
because there's gonna be no alternative
we will be story telling like this all
of us at scale until the next thing
Google glass [ __ ] Mars but it's
coming you know but for the next short
turn this isn't going away this isn't
gonna be a bus where that's gone we may
call it something else right call it
augment that [ __ ] I don't give a [ __ ]
but what it is is telling stories where
people actually are that's the upside
the upside is if you want to sell stuff
14 to 17 year olds there's about a
shitload time online and if you turn a
lot of spots tell a story in six seconds
that loops you're not gonna win period
yes sir
nothing's you talk about this and they
all work
a story or agency give us a story to
tell right I tell if you don't
but it sounds like with your slang your
translation there knowing the platforms
you're probably those pieces of content
plus pitching stories to them left and
right
so where do you see the stories so we
look at ourselves as DJ's right
everybody has to be are for doing events
these are big brands today bill
everybody's got story next time
something tells you they want stories
punch them in the face tell their loser
you're a loser if you don't realize that
there's a really big stories up from
many stories are everywhere right
they're absolutely everywhere you may
not have the talent to visually see them
I walk around I'm seeing stories all day
there's funny haircuts in here there's
plenty of stories it's just you have to
understand how to create that and by the
way let's let's let's let's put a stake
in the ground right now
storytelling is hard this is the talent
this isn't like everybody can [ __ ] do
it
it's hard just like everything's long
there's all sorts of skills that are
hard this is a hard one for me I got
lucky that the culture what a teepee
it's how I'm wired it's good like I do
you know I have tough stories not
reporting characters give me more I
struggle like but it's funny platforms
can force you medium I don't know how
many of you guys are checking out medium
it's a bit incredible to me what medium
has forced me in thinking and how I
started down that path because the
restrictions and the UI and so anyway
wheat DJ right we come up with our own
but remember we're very business focused
like we're looking at depletion reports
we're looking at [ __ ] that's going on
because we may want to tell story just
in Florida because our Jesus isn't doing
this about this month that's so like
we're targeting it like what people care
about in Florida maybe the baseball team
is doing well their football others
there's just a million that's absurd
what you just said meaning meaning
somebody saying where's our story it's
forever right I'm like the guy that's
pack
to your product that's worth at your
company for 47 years as a story the
color you decided to use what's going up
like by the way it's also about cocktail
party skills like everybody talked well
not just react there's so much [ __ ]
being thrown out just for yeah I
actually never worry about stories I'm
just gonna look what everybody else is
saying and that makes you sense people
like to sense right that's your
perspective so you know I mean I don't
know I we don't struggle with that we
new content counters and dance we do it
breaking news when matters we know what
the business objectives are we know what
the voices whatever we you know we
definitely know the context of every
platform we knew better than anybody you
know proud to say that we I went find
you now January 27th I myself spent 11
p.m. to 3:00 in the morning three
straight weeks figuring it out right
we're gonna be [ __ ] national for my
POV didn't use this [ __ ] and now the
people that I've said in bringing
strategist that are telling me about
snapshot I'm like ain't dick do you have
it no it's this [ __ ] you have to
understand it you know and so sorry I
get a little feisty you know I feel like
I'm in a room of my peers we all
understand what's going on and like we
need that more courage to have the
actual conversation because I'm gonna
make a statement now I think it's more
for you personally than professionally
we're now live in a world where
everybody's on the record right we're
all more on the record you have more
upside for being historically right than
appeasing the client or your fellow
employees in the room today the never
people
and so that's what I'm trying to empower
my people if I were to listen I'm
actually trying to impose your will
against me at my organization but I try
to encourage them and it's a lot easier
than other organizations than the
sandbox that we work in it's better be
historically right because somebody's
watching people are hearing which would
be a lot of destruction and you want to
be on the right side of history on this
stuff because it's gonna be your soon
then the upside for you being right and
pushing the right stuff will then I just
see a lot of people biting your lips
senator you know their tongues and our
inner cheeks and not saying what they
know is right and just do what's right
for that moment for that one second for
that pitch for that boss and it's a
mistake questions hey there's the what's
your name Jack Jack you used the word
you opened up talking about access to go
back to your original what was that my
original thought about that is there's
gonna be a lot of content but what
people love is access and I'm talking
content to access I'm not talking behind
the same pictures of the GMA's it up
great I'm talking I'm talking like
livestream and like really like giving
people I think that I was able to build
my brands with access right people think
like no make yourself not accessible you
seem cooler I'm not completely the other
way which is well another way to be
successful is to be utilitarian and help
people and like actually answered their
questions and actually give a [ __ ] about
them wow what a weird concept even so
access I think matters meaning meaning
what can you give what kind of like
event or experience digitally can you
give a kind of very big on live
streaming I think live streaming and
then I can actually
people access to play with brands are
paying these athletes and celebrities
lots of money for endorsement like those
contracts are so skewed towards the
celebrity soccer brands to fight back
and get 20 minutes with Beyonce
you know from Pepsi and let her be on
live shouldn't save a lot of fans now
that changes their lives like a wink
from you know a tweet from I mean if you
go to high school right now the amount
of people that have like literally
printed out tweets from celebrities to
them like hanging in their locker like
access you know how to get max I spend a
lot of time on that look going on
spreecast them just answer the people's
questions you form such a deeper emotion
with them and so brands leverage
celebrities and you know that
interesting guy that Microsoft wrote a
story about what have that set as a call
to action and it'll be on Ustream or
whatever Microsoft's ism video system is
tonight for an hour for Q&A that like
deepens and I think access is very
untapped potential
sure
so knowing that all of us here creating
content much of it is 800 work posts
them you've written for us others other
experts but you know what's what sort of
the next thing that we should be
focusing on is it all about the
real-time responsive is it about access
purely or are there other things that we
can do to make content interesting cool
yes so I think it's the things that you
know I don't believe in that many things
for the next 36 months what I would do
when you guys pay me to write for open
forum what you should be asking for that
a thrill that you don't is hey Gary not
only write that but can you be available
literally what I just saw that could you
be available from 7:00 to 8:00 on our
platform like that's the move you should
put into the contract that's number one
number two is the DJ back to the
question over there when you get an
article from me and you're putting it
out there you guys are using social
networks as distribution you guys tweet
out hey Gary you just wrote this cool
article about family businesses link and
you post it you need to be doing what
the book I guess you guys are all
getting or whatever sounds like the book
that I just wrote is about what I think
you should do which is you should take
the video you know that I usually make
and find that one funny part where I got
ridiculous which I always do an animated
gif and post it on tumblr and you've
been a chance to actually draw or spin
shot at me going crazy and then putting
a mean text over it and post that on
Facebook not just the link that says
there's a gap so like there is so much
upside if you actually respected these
and then wait for a hashtag that's
trending that was a theme similar to
mine like we did something for the Jets
during when the governor was shut down
hashtag shutdown was treading forever
well the Jets have a quarterback that we
wish was a little bit more of a shutdown
Aaron Cromartie that's a term into the
wall we use that hashtag when we were
putting out something about him and
we've waited for it to retread and we
got much more analytics on it much more
minutes now you can argue contextually
to get the right ones but it's
definitely still better than the
baseline that we would have gotten so
what you should do is you get that piece
of content you should do two things
create access and number two DJ that
content to give it a chance to get more
awareness in the platforms maybe you
take my whole thing and have somebody
internally create an infographic about
it and post it on your Pinterest because
infographics are grossly over indexing
right now and so like this kind of work
right
maybe you chop it up there's six seconds
that worked and put that on your mind
we are not DJing or aesthetically
contextualizing the content to give it
that I look at the soybean that works as
a gateway drug you have to look at it as
a gateway it's just you know it used to
be a nickel bag and next thing you know
you're selling coke it works
you know I'm so like we have to look at
the little pieces of content instead
what everybody's doing it's just
literally using it for distribution
right you guys do I know my watch
you know you get my piece you put it up
got your fix look into it I think Oh
scaredy article lanes and you're done
people are very lazy about social
network marketing right now
very lazy because it's early and they
don't understand the full ROI
they haven't tested and make sense I get
it it's just single game over and over
now we have the out brains and exit
ramps and all this stuff going on
content networks and there's just so
much going on there's so much
opportunity but the number one thing we
have to go in thinking is the content
secondary believe it or not the content
not secondary it's an equal partner to
the context of where we say it and so it
matters yes
yeah
the most people don't carry a bunch of
social networks feature Scott remembers
a lot of different people so it's not
about everybody's gonna use everything
that's really it's not really
complicated question to answer for me
right like to me it's all that someone
would say analytical like if there's 85
million people using vinyl in a 13 to 22
year old demo do you want to do business
with 13 to 22 year olds you need to give
a [ __ ] whether you like it or not you
know this whole notion to me that's been
the part that's blowing my mind being in
rooms where people are actually making
decisions and plan homes based on their
singular me I don't and we all laugh
because a lot of us have seen that like
you're like we have to do this there's
George a million of your customers that
do get it so let's figure out the
storytelling they're fast
yes so you talked about people not
understanding the value of what you do
and having sort of sell the value of
what you're doing do you have people who
go the other way and come to you and say
I need a viral meme tomorrow maybe not
and don't understand I talk about we
tell all our clients we send one of your
deals and we tell them basically we're
not gonna bring you any value for the
first part of 20 days so we entertain
that cars well we're not a campaign
business
right you know something you need to
like fix a fire real fast there's way
better places than me to go to right
there's retargeted banner ads there's PR
that can do some really good work
there's good places for that we just
don't have to be that first 90 days
we're testing and learning your end user
other sandwich stories to tell hey
hey Tory
yeah so the resource question is the
biggest thing I think about every day
which is we are on the verge of a
massive shift of working and non-working
media and the dollars allocated to them
so for the first time ever my price the
quality of the content is the
distribution you know you made the best
commercial of all time 15 years ago and
you paid Viacom a lot of money to like
distribute it even if it was the best it
would only get run it as much as you
paid for it but it's the first time
because the way these networks work and
word-of-mouth plumbing and all that if
you put out good content it actually
gets shared and so you get extra
impressions and stories as the market
gets educated they will start applying
more dollars to the actual creative then
the distribution Missi dollars siphoning
I feel it my scoops are all going up
this year and so I think the reason
you've fallen into that it's the same
reason all of us have fallen into it
because there's a mandate from the CFO
level of how much money you can actually
put on the creative versus how much
people in distribution once everybody
gets wise that the distribution is
predicated on the quality of the content
so like I said my team all the time
Gary's speaking of time we've taken a
lot of years thanks very much thank you
guys